they told me I was a lineman not a front  man there's a big chance every single  person from the media showed up I have a  major announcement it's  a team  jingle bells jingle all the way oh my  [Music]  mics Eagle Mania swept the nation and  manage that for me Nikki siriani I heard  you looking for a little of that  Nashville sound tell Crockett had Rango  wanted to add some jellies he means  Sirianni added some folks things did get  a little weird when the band entered  their Batman era  Bruce Wayne they were the Eagles but  then they had bats it was too many  animals you've changed Jason I'm  supposed to be the hot brother You're a  mean one Mr Snyder thank you  we got upstaged by the Commanders  maybe I could play  we had to get back to what got us there  in the first place no rules just right  this one goes out to all the haters We  wish you a merry  [Music]  Christmas